Maria and Nadia drive from Philadelphia
to Toronto to visit their friend they
take two days for the trip stopping
along the way for sightseeing to
conserve on gas mileage they drive at a
constant speed for the entire trip all
right which of the following equations
where X represents hours and y
represents miles represents a speed that
is greater than Maria and Nadia's speed
select all that apply
so let's think about what's happening
here so on day one they tear Apple for
four hours and they go 240 miles so if
we wanted to figure out their speed you
would figure out distance divided by
time so they travel 240 miles in 4 hours
240 divided by 4 is or 240 miles divided
by 4 hours is 60 miles per hour so
they're going 60 miles per hour and
assuming they went on the constant speed
the whole time they should have been
going 60 miles per hour on day 2 as well
and we can verify that 60 miles per hour
times 5 hours is indeed 300 miles where
300 divided by 5 is 60 so they went 60
miles per hour so which of these
equations represent a relation between
time elapsed and hours and distance that
represents faster than 60 miles per hour
well this is here you're taking the time
times 60 to get distance which is what
we did over here time times 60 to get
distance which is exactly their speed
but we care about a speed that is
greater and so pretty much all of these
other coefficients are faster so here
you're taking your time times 65 miles
per hour to get so you're going to go
more distance more than 60 miles per
hour in this situation here you're going
70 miles per hour
here you're going 80 miles per hour now
we got it right let's do one more some
vinyl records let's call them oldies
rotate at the rate of 78 revolutions per
minute the chart below shows revolutions
per minute for three different tracks on
another type of vinyl record called
goodies which has a greater rate of
revolution oldies or goodies so oldies
are 78 revolutions per minute let's
think
about these revolutions per minute right
over here so in three minutes this one
makes 135 revolutions so how many per
minute so if we divide revolutions by
minutes you're going to get let's see 3
goes into 135 it looks like it would go
into let's see 3 goes into 120 40 times
so it looks like it goes 45 times so
it's 45 revolutions per minute for track
1 track 2 it's also 45 4 times 45 if I
have 45 revolutions per minute times 4
minutes that's 160 plus 20 yep that's
180 so these are all 45 revolutions per
minute you can multiply 5 times 5
minutes times 45 revolutions per minute
you're going to get 225 so the oldies go
at 78 rpm so they do 78 revolutions in a
minute while the goodies go 45 so the
oldies go do more revolutions in a
minute
so oldies have a greater rate of
revolution per minute or rotate or they
have a greater rate of revolution per
minute